a suspect surrounded 30 miles from the
ballroom dancehall where the massacre
happened inside the white van was this
man 72 year old who can Tran alleged to
have shot dead 10 people and injured
scores more
his body found slumped in the driver's
seat but troubling questions remain
what was the motive for this shooter
did he have a mental illness
was he a domestic violence abuser
how did he get these guns and was it
through legal means or not
it had been a Saturday of Celebration
here this was the eve of Chinese New
Year in a predominantly Asian American
city
but after night fell as a ballroom dance
class took place the gunman opened fire
he then went to another dance venue in
the nearby city of Alhambra The Killing
Spree would probably have continued but
he was disarmed by two people
this quiet community rocked by violence
it really is really sad
I was looking forward to be here
celebrating but
even if I'm not celebrating them I'm
part with them so I wanted to be here
and like
tell the Asian community that they're
very special to me he is the deadliest
shooting in California in recent memory
this was supposed to be day two of the
Chinese New Year celebrations but
they're taking down the signs and
dismantling the Stalls because Monterey
Park is now the focus of America's gun
violence academic
another mass shooting means another
chorus of calls for gun control
legislation it's difficult for a lot of
people to understand yes an individual
can get hold of such a powerful weapon
that can kill 10 people yes of course
you know thank you bro they only have
one 30 round magazine put on the rep and
they can kill many people gun is a
danger gun only for the people
professional like law enforcement or
they need that if not why you need the
gun this land need your father local
people gathered to pray the immediate
danger may have passed here but gun
violence is the never-ending scourge of
life in this country
Martha Kellner Sky News Monterey Park